bon spider man 3 comment vous dire c'est
un bordel
non vraiment je crois que c'est vraiment
quelque chose d'inédit je ne me rappelle
vraiment pas avoir déjà vu quelque chose
comme ça mais avant ça j'aimerais quand
même vous souhaiter une très bonne année
je vous souhaite que tous vos projets
vos rêves se réalisent et puis voilà
quoi que le line up soit avec vous tout
simplement également j'ai un petit
cadeau pour vous fut un temps où j'avais
un discorde où je parlais avec vous et
cetera j'ai changé sur la pop culture
et ce discours fut un petit peu laissé à
l'abandon
sachez que ce dernier a été remis à neuf
et que du coup bas il tourne autour de
la pop culture notamment les sujets dont
nous parlons sur la chaîne principale où
le projet est vraiment de pouvoir
échanger entre les personnes en gros
quoi de autour de notre passion et donc
réunir les gens quoi donc que vous soyez
fans de marvel de star wars ou d'autre
chose n'hésitez pas et je vous laisserai
d'ailleurs découvrir le concept de hype
temporaire sur le discorde
enfin sachez que vous êtes très nombreux
à regarder les vidéos sans être abonné à
la chaîne n'hésitez pas à nous rejoindre
vous ne louperez plus aucune sortie de
vidéos et puis moi ça m'encourage
beaucoup aller sur ce il est temps de
passer au spectacle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous vous souvenez tous du gros conflit
qu'il ya eu entre marvel fin soit plutôt
disney et sony pour faire bref spider
man appartient à sony sony prête
spider man à disney pour intégrer le mc
eu et ensemble ils se partagent les
bénéfices
voilà grossièrement parlant il faut le
comprendre comme ça mais évidemment ce
sont des accords qui sont bien plus
complexe que ça entre les visions
créatives différentes de sony et marvel
l'argent les produits dérivés comme les
jouets et caetera et c'est le problème
avec ce genre d'accord entre deux
énormes entreprises comme marvel studios
sony sait que cela ne pourra jamais
durer éternellement
et là où cet intrigant c'est que
l'accord qui était censée s'arrêter
après spider man far from home a été
renouvelé et ce pour au moins deux films
un troisième film solo qui est le sujet
de la vidéo ainsi qu'une apparition dans
un autre film en tant qu'invité à la
manière de l'apparition de speedy au
black panther dans un civil war c'est ce
nouvel accord qu il faut comprendre et
décortiqué pour mieux appréhender
l'avenir de peter parker dans le cinéma
notamment ce spider man 3 sony souhaite
relancer spider man et c'est vraiment un
objectif important pour le succès de
venom des a conforté dans cette idée et
c'est un tout nouvel univers qui
commence à se bâtir le spyder verse
sauf que c'est encore trop tôt et vous
allez comprendre pourquoi
le mc u est beaucoup trop puissant
aujourd'hui dans la catégorie des super
héros l'univers il riche cohérent et
surtout spider man s'intègre très bien à
l'univers il a de l'avenir des films
solo qui ont marché
bref si sony souhaite retirer spider man
du mc eu pour enfin lancer leur spyder
verse ils vont autodétruire leurs
projets il faut bien comprendre qu'à
terme spider man partira du mc eu pour
retourner chez sony sauf qu effectué un
énième reboot pour créer leur propre
histoire de spider man serait une perte
considérable de temps et d'argent
surtout que tom holland est censé rester
l'acteur de spider man un détail qui
ruinerait encore plus la chose car c'est
le meilleur moyen de rendre confus le
spectateur puisque ce sera le même
acteur dans le
mc eu que dans le spyder verse de sony
mais ce ne sera pas le même spider man
est pas la même histoire
sans parler du fait que les deux
histoires seront constamment mis en
confrontation et enfin voilà ce n'est
pas le but recherché quoi de plus le mc
u permet de promouvoir à pleine
puissance le spider man joué par tom
holland
on parle quand même d'un héros qui est
apparu dans infinity ward qui a fait un
score de plus de 2 milliards de dollars
au box office et 2 milliards 798
millions avec endgame le plus gros
succès de l'histoire du box office
donc une vitrine incroyable pour le
jeune super héros une mise en avant qui
n'auraient pas autant d'impact si bas
spider man était seulement chez sony et
bien sûr comme l'a dit kevin fergie
spider man se trouve être le seul héros
avec la surpuissance pour traverser les
univers cinématographique et c'est là
qu'on va pouvoir commencer à balancer de
la théorie l'objectif est de perdurer
l'histoire de peter parker du mc eu dans
l'univers de sony et ce de façon
cohérente pour récupérer les fans du mca
et proposer leur vision avec tout ce qui
a déjà été établie
[Musique]
spider man étant plutôt jeune et bien ce
dernier a besoin d'une figure paternelle
comme l'était originellement en club n
c'est un rôle qui sera dans le mc eu
endossé par tony stark notamment dans
homecoming film présente anthony comme
un véritable modèle héroïque et mentor
pour le jeune peter parker incarné par
un tome hollande au meilleur de sa forme
un rôle qui perdurera dans far from home
même si étant décédé nick fury prendra
en quelque sorte le relais
donc voilà strange est le seul héros
pour le moment annoncée dans spider man
3 provenant du mcm et pas qu'en simple
caméo
mais avec une véritable présence strange
est un véritable pilier pour le mc eu un
héros qui va prendre encore plus de
poids au vu de ce qui est attendu à
l'avenir il est là le nouveau mentor de
speedy pour son troisième film néanmoins
il existe quelque chose d'important a
souligné même s'ils se sont déjà côtoyés
dans infinity ward
peter et strange n'ont rien en commun
ils ne sont pas proches ils ne sont pas
amis bref vous avez compris l'idée donc
cela signifie que si strange intègre
spider man 3 pour être aux côtés de
peter ce ne sera pas par gentillesse
mais pour une véritable raison une
raison qui entourent l'impact des
réalités l arrivée du multivers le seul
vrai héros en comprendre les ficelles et
les manipuler tony a été un mentor pour
peter dans le rôle en lui-même de super
héros l'impact des pouvoirs de speedy
nick fury a été un mentor dans
l'importance de devoir prendre ses
responsabilités speedy est un à 20
heures il a la capacité d'agir est de
sauver les gens
il doit l'assumer avec spider man 3
strange sera un mentor pour peter
concernant le multivers
et la multitude de réalité existante
dans l'univers que peter n'est qu'un
simple spider man parmi tant d'autres
mais qu'il a tout de même un rôle à
accomplir
[Musique]
bon avec tout ce que nous avons déjà dit
pour le moment je pense que votre vision
commence un petit peu à s'éclaircir
l'arrivée des simister 6 commence à se
faire ressentir chez beaucoup de monde
et notamment par le biais du retour de
certains acteurs d'anciens méchant de
spider on pense évidemment à electro
joué par jamie foxx le même acteur qui
jouait déjà électro dance the amazing
spider man 2 ou encore docteur octopus
incarné par alfred molina qui dans le
même schéma était déjà le docteur
octopus de spider man 2 de la trilogie
de sam raimi et ces informations ne sont
vraiment pas à prendre à la légère
pourquoi faire rejouer les mêmes acteurs
que dans les anciens spider man il y a
un gros risque de confondre les
personnages si c'est un reboot et si
c'était un reboot de ces méchants
pourquoi aller chercher ces acteurs
spécifique alors qu'il ya plein d'autres
acteurs que vous posez la même question
pour toby mais on va y revenir dans un
délire de film ultime pour lancer le
spyder se réunissent en tous cas créer
sony par le passé le retour de ses
personnages le quand évidemment tout
l'aspect multi vers le fait que comme
hollande soit l'acteur du spider man
capable de traverser les univers
cinématographique faire revenir
octopus ou bien électro et ils ne seront
certainement pas les seuls personnages à
ressurgir du passé permet de consolider
l'univers qui essaie d'instaurer sony de
relancer tout l'univers spyder verse
faire renaître les deux anciennes
trilogie si nous sommes face aux mêmes
méchant que dans les anciens films il
n'y aura pas besoin de raconter les
origines story des méchants vu qu'elle
existe déjà il y aura juste a expliqué
comment les univers se sont retrouvés
reliés
et on est obligé d'évoquer le cas des
six mr 6 et il ya du lourd a souligné
par le biais de spider man 3 sony va
pouvoir balancer une sorte de mini
avengers endgame promouvant totalement
le spyder verse et ce film va être un
moment clé pour la saga avant ça pour
rappel le petit moment histoire
si mr 6 est le nom d'un groupe de super
vilains se réunissant pour se venger de
spider man un style qui aurait ruiné
tous leur grand projet de ville 1 le
groupe se compose selon les versions de
dr octopus à l'origine du regroupement
du vautour d'électro cravenne de
mystérieux et enfin fameux homme sable
sony a pour projet de faire un film
autour des sinistres 6 et c'est très
révélateur sans spider man qui est
encore dans le mc eu sony a pour
objectif de proposer des films autour
des personnages iconiques voir méchants
de l'univers spider man nous avons déjà
eu venom qui a été un franc succès et
mobius semble être le prochain sur la
liste
deux ennemis de spider man une fois
spider man 3 sorties avec le retour des
anciens méchant sony souhaite ressortir
de leurs cartons le projet sinister 6 un
film qui est prévu depuis des années
mais dont sony attendait le bon moment
pour le faire émerger un film qui
pourraient raconter l'origine du
regroupement des super vilains
présentant spider man 3 également il est
vrai que dans les comics spider man pas
à lui seul les sinister 6 mais bon
pas péjoratif d'avouer que le peter
parker de tom holland n'est pas vraiment
en capacité il n'a pas la carrure pour
vaincre ses ennemis expérimenté à la
suite
lens est encore beaucoup trop tôt et il
a besoin d aide
[Musique]
déjà il est important de préciser une
chose ce film est le troisième long
métrage solo du spider man du mc ce qui
signifie que peu importe ce que nous
verrons tom holland est l'acteur
principal du film peter parker du mc eu
reste le personnage principal et nous
serons témoins de son histoire une
histoire qui pourrait être chamboulée
avec l'élément perturbateur que son
identité a été révélée par mystérieux
grand public
une révélation qui propulserait les
antagonistes à retrouver facilement
peter ainsi que sa famille concernant
tôt bay maggie re pardon excuse moi mais
on dit aubé maguire attention tu parles
du meilleur spider man la merci maistre
concernant toby mcguire et andrew
garfield
tout comme les sinister 6 créé le retour
de ces personnages permet d'éviter de
raconter leur histoire et voir de les
reboot puisque nous les connaissons déjà
par le biais de leur trilogie mais
surtout cela va permettre d'équilibrer
le combat face aux sinistres 6 et encore
plus ce sont des personnages qui ont
tous échoué face à spider man et chaque
méchant possède un background lié à l'un
des trois spider man il y a plusieurs
liens de confrontation qui sont déjà
existants néanmoins il faut faire très
attention à une fausse hype créé nous
restons dans le m6 et même si sony prête
à marvel leur spider man incarné par tom
holland
cela ne veut pas dire qu'ils vont les
laisser manipuler librement les spider
man incarné par toby ou encore andrew il
se pourrait que la présence des autres
spider man soit simplement pour la fin
du film voir une scène post générique
il se pourrait que le film spider man 3
soit un simple cheminement pour tom
holland qui le conduirait aux côtés de
doctor strange à voir la naissance du
multivers des réalités la prise de
conscience qui n'est pas le seul spider
man que son identité révélée n'est pas
une fin en soi et que le véritable
combat réunissant les trois spider man
face aux sinistres 6 se passera quand
sony aura récupéré leurs héros enfin
comment justifier la transition vers un
autre univers cinématographique
étant donné que tom holland incarnera
spider man dans normalement le second
film du docteur strange qui on en
reparlera mais il semble être le
prochain gros film réunissant de grands
personnages un peu à la manière de civil
war et bien le film étant axée sur le
multivers dans un acte héroïque ou un
piège tendu par les nih tom holland
pourrait se perdre dans les réalités et
atterrirait dans l'univers de sony c'est
vraiment une question difficile car
évidemment
peter à mary jane tante may api pourquoi
il partirait dans une autre réalité par
contrainte ou obligation forcément nous
arrivons à la fin de cette vidéo et je
dois vous avouer que même s'il y a très
très peu d'informations à part le le
retour de certains acteurs eh bien il ya
quand même des choses à dire des
questions à se poser des mystères à
élucider ce film ne sera vraiment pas
comme les autres tout simplement car
l'aspect irl l'aspect de la vraie vie on
va dire prend le dessus sur l'aspect
fictif de la saga les accords joue
beaucoup trop le marketing tout l'aspect
commercial aussi etc etc
nous sommes carrément face à une sorte
de multivers dans la vraie vie entre le
passage de disney à sony je suis très
heureux en tout cas d'avoir pu vous
parler de tout ça en vidéo et en plus
avec des guest de qualité je pense que
nous pourrons potentiellement revenir
sur le sujet dans les prochaines
semaines car il ya vraiment énormément
de choses à parler a vous de me dire si
vous êtes chaud donc bien évidemment un
énorme merci aux copains maistre
thibault
le bon vieux bros heroes sef la trinité
est enfin venu sachez en tout cas
qu'avec heroes du coup on vous propose
une double vidéo c'est à dire que du
coup en ce moment même vous regardez la
vidéo mais lui aussi a sorti une vidéo
sur sa chaîne où j'apparais dedans et
dont le sujet spider man 3 évidemment
bref n'hésitez pas à laisser un petit
pouce bleus à vous abonner à la chaîne
comme je vous disais puis un petit
commentaire avec vos idées vos théories
et cetera
et puis pour les plus intéressés qui ont
vidé changé autour de marvel de star
wars ou de la pop culture en général bah
je voulais ce chéquier le lien du
discorde en descriptions aller c'était
argot rock on se retrouve très très
prochainement pour de nouvelles vidéos
parce que l'avait avoir quelques sorties
à l'est que le live art soit avec vous
ciao
[Musique]